bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon émission spéciale défense
sicilienne la citizen d'âge d'or le coût
6 x 3 avec stéphane laborde bonjour
stéphane bonjour et loi ce coup-ci ce
fougueux 3 a été joué par gary kasparov
wen a été jouée par tout les grands
joueurs de sicilienne avec les blancs
tous les grands joueurs 2,4 c'est une
des variantes les plus dangereuses
c'est une erreur n'est plus dangereuse
aussi les plus compliqués les blancs
veulent très vite l'ancien lensois
d'options aller loin avec s3 et g 4 et
le fou et 3a lorgne notamment la case b6
ou va s'installer un cabinet noir
c'est évidemment un plan d' attaque
régulièrement jouer avec des rocs opposé
donc la cdp reniant tous les blancs font
le grand roque c'est une sorte d'
attaque anglaise c'est la formation avec
f3 g4 on vous commentera tout à l'heure
donc cette ouverture stéphane est très
très dangereuse il faut connaître
précisément c'est ce qu'on va montrer
aujourd'hui c'est dangereux pour les
deux camps c'est dangereux pour les deux
camps puisqu'on sait que le meilleur
joueur gagne dans cette position puisque
gary kasparov qui les blancs et les
noirs gagne reagan à chaque fois il y en
a chaque fois avec les de couleur or et
savoir ce qu'il ferait si je veux
contrôler lui-même exactement donc
capable de gagner deux fois avec les
blanc et noirs il n'ya que rambo qui
peut battre en beau c'est bien connu
donc nous allons tout de suite vous
montrer les coûts de cette ouverture
six fautes 3 une des variantes les plus
dangereuses pour jouer contre le nashor
donc échiquier et c'est parti eux quatre
ces cinq cavaliers f3 des six des 4,6
idées nouvelles
donc ouais si on prend des quatre kelly
prend des quatre le coût normal qu'avec
des filles et si ça sent les blancs
répondent par cas mais les c3 maintenant
à six la neige d'or nous sommes en plein
dedans
hélas le coup f3 stéphane on se rappelle
que la dernière fois nous avions vu le
système de scheveningen qui est un peu
différent on est tout à fait puisque les
blancs ne joue pas et qu'elle 3 mais ils
jouent tout simplement fou et deux dans
cette position et ensuite avec petit
rock foo étroit et f4 donc là vous
pourrez regarder dans les archives
didier donnât l'émission sur le système
de chef d'un gang et vous trouverez donc
exactement cette position ici le coup et
6 f3 ou s'il faut 3 c'est une inversion
de coûts l'idée ça évite des sous-marins
tf3 parce que sur fouet trois les noirs
peuvent quand même joué cavalier g4
directement qui rentre dans une variante
un peu différente
on montrera tout à l'heure les quelques
subtilités
il ya également des inconvénients
notamment ici et noir peuvent par
exemple joué le 5 mai pour généraliser
tout ça qu'il joue au 6e coup donc dans
cette position présente le coup f3 ou le
couffo 3 nous répondrons pareil nous
jouerons le coup à 6 2-6 donc qu'il
reconnaît tout de suite la structure du
petit 120 très souple maintenant cette
foulée 3 à l'orienter aussi quant à eux
trois le fou va pas gêner la revente et
des pions blancs c'est à dire qu'on va
jouer j'ai 4 gsm évidemment si on a
déjoué ou g5 se serait pas possible donc
tout de suite les devants la première
remarque stéphane ils vont a priori
faire le grand roque ont pour pouvoir
pousser lors d'options h2g2 tels des
béliers qui vont donc pulvérisé la
position du roi noir est normalement lui
warocqué du petit côté ouais alors c'est
là justement une des premières règles
dans cette ouverture
on n'est pas pressé de roque et il faut
absolument pas donner l'adresse de son
roi c'est la relève sinon sa part ok
c'est sûr que lève la poussée de ses
pions blancs vont enfin peu dans le vide
elle est dangereuse quand même puisque
effectivement l'idée des blancs c'est
d'arriver à jouer j'ai 5 h 5
et dans cette pression jouer j'ai six
points coût qui sera dévastateur sur les
cases blanches notamment le pion au site
il sera faible
le pion à vii et tout ça c'est quand
même autour de la position de roi noir
il n'est jamais question pratiquement
pour les noirs de jury pour rock
il faut donc laisser l'europe centre est
très vite la seule chose à faire quand
on est attaqué stéphane c'était de
contre attaquer ces deux contre-attaqués
donc directement des cinq mois la b5 à
noter que les blancs on n'aurait pas pu
jouer à 4 pour un pichet b5 puisque dans
ce cas là si je vois quatre ils
affaiblissent leur propre grand donc
exactement donc s'il joue avec à 4 les
blancs ne peuvent plus jouer avec rock
et tout de suite s'ils peuvent pas jouer
les crocs
il devient très délicat de pousser le
pion en g4 c'est normal puisque le roi
blanc va quand même se retrouver
affaiblie
ici deux coups possibles la dame en d2
où le coup j'ai 4 donc ça c'est les deux
possibilités on va tout de suite regardé
le coup j'ai 4 donc c'est une partie
great choc contre garry kasparov qui
était joué la coupe du monde de came
donc partie de référence évidemment
greccio très bien préparé c'est un tueur
de cécilienne garry kasparov s'est le
plus fervent défenseur de cette défense
sicilienne donc ici g4 est joué l'idée
c'est d'éviter
et certaines variantes mais de toute
façon ça change pas grand chose ici les
noirs vont organiser leurs deux
cavaliers donc c'est très curieux parce
que stéphane comme on le sait il faut
pas jouer deux fois avec les mêmes
pièces en ouverture oui alors lazio qui
se pose un problème au noir c'est le
développement du cavalier b8 c'est à
dire si ce cavalier baby tu ne peux pas
venir un c6 puisque le cahier des quatre
contrôles et s'il vient sur la case 17
eh bien ils enlèvent une case à l'autre
cavaliers donc en poussant le g5 on
poussera ce cavalier à la bande
exactement règle donc une des règles
principales
quand vous êtes dans ce genre de
position et bien ce cavalier m6 ne doit
jamais partir sur la case h5 madou qui
serait pas très efficace quand il serait
mal placé il serait substitut
susceptible pardon d'être attaqué donc
il faut absolument pas le mettre là ce
cavalier f6 toujours retard sur la pièce
17 puisque évidemment il va partir et
blanc vont jouer chez 5 ça c'est évident
ici donc il faut replacer les deux
cavaliers lequel évite et cavaliers this
on n'est pas pressé de bouger le fois de
suite
encore une règle dans cette ouverture
stéphane puisque je vous ai fuite en
recettes ça apporte pas grand chose
sachant que les noirs n'ont pas une
envie particulière de rock et ouais
parce que pour l'instant on est plus ou
moins les pions blancs sont quand même
menaçant les pions blancs sont menaçants
donc quand cette pression tu l'as dit on
ne joue pas qui a et b 17 puisqu'après
de g5
tout de suite on est une douce t des
fois je vois g5 tout de suite parce que
sinon les noirs ont le temps de jouer qu
amélie b 6 oui tout à fait donc ici on
joue cavalier f17 comme ça au moins
notre cavalier ne sera plus attaquer
quand les blanches orangées 5 et les
blancs vont jouer g5 bientôt dam des
deux ici on continue à s'organiser on
joue cavalier b6
donc ça c'est on va voir que les deux
cavaliers vont trouver des emplacements
bien particulier ouais c'est très
typique dans cette position le leader
cavani v6 stéphane c'est pas forcément
de calais ses cadres n'ont pas
satisfaire une pièce du côté du grand
roque des blancs donc maintenant le
deuxième cavaliers aussi va pas être
loin le fouet fuite lorgn quand même sur
la case à 3 et puis manquera plus qu'à
activer le fou s'est vite si on arrive à
l'activé toutes les pièces lorgneront
vers leurs grands requins blancs
exactement grand requis 6 très logique
cavaliers 817 donc toujours ce duo de
cavaliers qui se déploie damev de alors
ça c'est un pou
on peut également envisager stéphane
pour les blancs de jouer par exemple un
coup comme h4 ouais ça c'est possible h4
alors maintenant plein de plein de
réactions possibles pour les noirs
notamment donc on a toujours envie de
jouer avec des 5
ça c'est le fameux coup libérateur dans
la défense sicilienne donc ici on peut
tout à fait envisager de jouer
stéphane b 4 way le cavalier doit partir
sur la case au dos par exemple sur la
tête alors la casse au dos il ya un gros
problème tout de suite c'est le bouquet
sahel tc4 qui prend le faux 3 mais il a
pas beaucoup de casse ou camille alors
le cavalier doit plutôt partir sur les
traces b1 gaz assez moche ouais
et ici on pourra jouer je pense à priori
le coup libérateur des six des 5
pourquoi parce que le cas est bien très
mal placé les blancs ont perdu du temps
en jouant jusqu'à jay 4 et donc la
réaction contre une attaque allen
on le dit souvent stéphane leur action
centré action au centre parfaite la
réaction au centre puisque en cas de
prise
on reprend du cavalier le cabinet donc
très fort en d5 qui attaquent le foin 3
et le cavaly b1 des blancs très mal
placé ça c'est tout le problème des
blancs est ici donc effectivement tout
les problèmes
le problème bien que après ab4 justement
on ne peut pas jouer cavalier à eux deux
là effectivement il serait bien plus
bien mieux placé pour riposter contre
des 5 puisqu'il serait encore dans
l'action on peut pêcher qui a eu lieu à
cause de kayes s'écartera pour le donc
ici après calais 8 17 directement la
menace c'est des quatre dames f2 donc ça
c'est une réaction logique puisque
maintenant sur b4 on va jouer le
cavalier sur la case de 2 km ces cartes
ne nous fait pas peur on se conservent
intact lui la dame fou bessette ça c'est
complètement le plan classique
malencontreux très bien la case des
scènes pour jouer le coup libérateur des
six des 5
à noter que lecavalier en dix-sept
empêche les blancs de fermer la position
avec l'a45 ce qui est important aussi
c'est extrêmement important quand vous
êtes prêt à jouer dès six dessins qui
est un coup thématique le coup
libérateur no
dufour et fuite le coût qui va ouvrir un
petit peu la position au centre si les
blancs ont perdu trop de temps à pousser
leurs pions
ça c'est ce qu'il faut voir et bien à ce
moment là le coût des 5 devient
extrêmement puissants mais il faut
contre la casse de 5 il faut pas que les
blancs puis sperme et en jouant aux 4 5
fu détroit joué par great choc ici là on
pourrait jouer dès 4 et des 5 c'est
aussi mais kasparov a vu mieux
il a vu tours s'est vite pour ses 8
points dans cette position qui menace le
coût pour ces vies tranquilles et c3
sacrifice de qualité donc ça perd une
tour contre un cavalier mais les blancs
reprenant avec l'option b 2 se retrouve
dans une situation extrêmement délicate
extrêmement délicate c'est le thème de
la partie 9 sessions entre kasparov qui
a été jouée dans un tournoi qu on vous
montrera par la suite donc en c3 est une
menace dans cette position donc rude
choc à jouer car les ce2 et ensuite
donc là on va s'arrêter très
prochainement on va juste regarder qu'à
et c5 de kasparov
ils menacent de prendre le fou en d3 une
fois que ce fonds est pris on joue des
saintes très fort cassant toutes les
cases blanches roi bien maintenant sur
la prise du fou on reprend avec l'option
et on renforce le centre c'est à dire qu
on se prémunit contre des simples en
renforçant notre centre mais maintenant
c'est à dire qu'on pouvait pas avant
puisque le roi était en échec par la
tour s'est vite extrêmement heureux tout
à fait tout à fait le fiancé de auraient
été floués quelle idée à 4 alors on voit
que ces deux cavaliers sont menaçants
quand même sont très menaçants très très
menaçants l'idc régulièrement de prendre
en d3 alors amené le deuxième cas penser
et le réflexe a pas ne pas avoir cédé
jouer b2 b3 qui est figurée complètement
le rock b3 c'est possible d'ailleurs
stéphanois a été choisi par judit polgar
ouais mais donc c'est tout à fait
possible ses intentions ces responsables
cmh responsabilité est vraiment fou et
cavaliers deuxième camion c5
voilà donc ça c'est un premier exemple
de partie mais effectivement l'idée
et c'est pas de vous apprendre à jouer
aussi loin que kasparov vous et vous
apprendre à jouer l'ouverture en général
donc là vous avez un très bon exemple
d'une partie menée par kasparov qui
aboutit à une position complexe
extrêmement complexe ici on voit qu'il
ya de la taxe des deux côtés 1 les bleus
ont gardé leur potentiel d'attac les
normes développées de leurs mets ici
une chose est sûre vous n'êtes pas
perdant vous n'êtes peut-être même par
moments bien c'est une position tout à
fait jouable et bien dans l'esprit de la
ccid yens il faut garder à l'idée et on
voit plein en retardant au maximum le
développement de leur fouet suite et de
la 3e suite
ils attendent de pouvoir jouer des cinq
avant d'obtenir le bouger donc ici au
programme
ces dames c'est 7 puis des 5% contre lui
la classe de ce1 qui voit là puisque la
d'avancé 7 contrôlera cette case aux 5
d'ailleurs c'est la suite de la partie
on va vous le montrer c'est très
instructif h4 dame ses sept tours c'est
un tour c'est un puisque la menace
s'était prendront des 3 et
éventuellement donc de bien contrôler
cette commune ces derniers de se
prémunir contre ça et maintenant des
cinq coups libérateur ici en tout cas
paniqué il a joué eux cinq dames 35 gens
plus pour garry kasparov et il a ensuite
transformé son essai donc nous allons
tout de suite vous montrer une nouvelle
partie qui donc la partie pour le gard
kasparov donc ça c'est en fait c'est la
même chose donc on va pas vouloir
montrer tout simplement une obsession
kasparov très intéressant également
donc si les premiers coups sont les
mêmes la d4 qui comprend des quatre
cavaliers prendre câbles et fils qui le
laisse croire as he is fuoh 3 x 3 cette
fois donc c'est un peu différent là les
noirs peuvent jouer le coup cavaliers g4
et qu'il rentre une sous variantes mais
très intéressante il faut que les blancs
répondent parfois g5 et ça devient très
compliqué ça devient très compliqué
effectivement notre objectif étant de
vous apprendre à jouer la ccn nash dorff
on ne va pas vous apprendre à jouer
toutes les variantes pour les noirs
puisqu'il suffit d'une seule
il suffit de jouer dans cette position
aussi ce qui est différent de kg 4 et
qui différencie du coût de 7,5 qui
existent également dans cette version
stephen aussi ce donc
c'est le coût normal f3 alors là fait un
effort pour vous rappeler ce qu'il faut
jouer
qu'est ce qu'on a dit stéphane et bien
il faut contre-attaqué faux contre
attaque est une première étape b5 dans
leur logique
ouais dam des deux et là on voit que les
blancs donc pas jouer g4 à la place de
dan d2 ils ont donc joué d'amd de tout
de suite moi ils n'ont pas encore bougé
car il n'ya pas gsm qui menacent donc on
peut jouer cavalier b17 voilà ce qui
n'est pas pareil puisque dans la
position où tu attends xhaka tg5
l'allier page et 5 beaucoup plus mettre
ce camilla grand roque broc
loïc est maintenant tombé cette voie la
foulée cette très logique aussi tant que
les blancs ne menace pas les 5
on garde le camion 17 g4 donc j'ai cas
maintenant menace g5 qui pousse le
cavalier la bande
donc c'est le bon moment pour jouer
notre cavalier pour libérer la casse des
fêtes exactement mon conjoint qui avait
six autres grandes variantes cb4 avec
une masse de terrorisme gigantesque on
va pas vous la montrer parce qu'elle est
trop compliqué trop compliqué il ya
beaucoup de lignes parker à apprendre et
c'est pas évidemment l'intérêt donc calé
les 6es l'appareil toujours le même
problème la menace dans cette position
cd4 qui force le cas et c'est 3 à partir
sur les traces bien rappelez vous bien
que une fois qu'il est en bien c'est le
moment on va pouvoir commencer à
envisager des 5 alors là peut-être pas
tout de suite parce que eux scène que
est possible pour les blancs pas tout de
suite parce qu'avec 5 mais que peuvent
faire les blancs dans cette position eu
pas grand chose s'il joue hk trompeuse
riquet 17 et menacé des quatre est
ensuite descendu donc d'un f2 d'un f2
avec une petite menace de judith cavale
et prend aussi ce qu'elle promeut 6 non
classés l'obsession ouais mais de pardon
qui est pro sys puisqu'après la batterie
fouet dame n'existait pas avant
va ramasser le cavalier en b 6 cavaliers
le 17
donc en otage deux cavaliers double
effet puisque ça protège le kenyan plus
et gagnent du temps 50 du temps parce
que quand il y aura g5 et bien moi ça
n'attaquera plus rien l'obsession du roi
b un tour s'est vite donc on voit que
c'est à peu près les mêmes coûts on
toujours c'est la même position sauf que
la dernière fois il y avait eu ce coup
le cabinet qui revient sur la case the
way s'annonce et s était pas ça en fait
la dernière fois les bienfaits du fou
des trois placements bien ouais tout à
fait permis qui a laissé venir là donc
il ya une petite faute de mots session
qui ne connaissait pas la partie puisque
celle là et a été joué avant et dans
cette position obsession se retrouve
très ennuyée oui parce que sur cavaliers
oduya qu'avait laissé quatre cas l'air
embêté en bas c'est ça qui avait lieu de
le problème c'est que le foot n'est pas
là donc on peut jouer des cinq moyens
proscrits je me devais descendre qui
tout de suite fait exploser le centre
mais et on voit que les pièces blanches
sont extrêmement mal placé donc on va
envisager ce coût est ici donc elle sait
cap effectivement stéphane c'est un bon
coup des 5
c'est un autre bon coup on peut montrer
également puisque là et bien tout de
suite en attaque le pian on peut pas
jouer saigne toujours très important sur
re5 lecavalier st quoique on peut
décaler prend aussi sa cause mais les
gens que je me sens enfin c'est assez
c'est assez chaud faire ses choux c'est
même très très tendue puisque il peut y
avoir calé ses quatre enfants ici les
noirs - très bon jeu de pièces c'est ça
qu'il faut dire on voit que le
développement des blancs est pas
terrible
la tour en h1 joue pas le fond elle
n'est pas encore sortie
alors que les noirs dans deux coups
fawcett est petit rock ils ont sorti
toutes leurs pièces est le centre est
ouvert
donc tout simplement équilibre dynamique
personne n'est en avance au niveau du
développement événement ou un meilleur
jeu de pièces le fou bessette et de la
forme
la tour s'est vite aussi le canadien b6
peut sauter en c4 ou aller en d5
bref les non sens bien après tours s'est
vite problème donc pour une obsession
qui jouent au foot est roi
donc il avait à se dire au roulement et
juste après je vais jouer cavalier ou
deux et je vais jouer maintenant cava22
tranquille mais la toile pensée 3 et wii
on leur thématique de thématiques alors
pas paf c'est quand même fou quand même
avoir les reins solides vous pouvez
insérer fiso qualité aussi tôt dans la
partie parce qu'on dit qu'au 13e coup
quand même nous sommes au troisième coup
mais ce sacrifice de qualité alors il
est particulier puisqu'en général l'idée
c'est de récupérer ensuite l'option 4
c'est à dire qu'on donne une tour pour
les minettes défenseur du chievo 4 et
ensuite on prend mais si c'est pas du
tout l'idée de garry kasparov puisque ça
tient ou 4 et blindés ouais convoitises
une fois l'idée c'est vraiment stéphane
la taxe sur leurs ouailles affaiblir les
cases noires l'affaiblissement des cases
noires élimination du défenseur
principal qui est autour du roi donc
après plus reprend ses droits
les noirs ne sont pas pressés dans cette
position ils n'ont pas envie de
récupérer tout de suite leur matériel
ils vont simplement ramener toutes leurs
pièces en choses et ensuite tout
simplement les blancs ne pourront pas se
défendre parce que cette structure de
pioche est très très difficile à
défendre et la tour de plus la tour
contre le cavalier supplémentaires
n'êtes pas dans cette défense n'y a pas
beaucoup de colonne ouverte
on va regarder le défilé coup ouais
dames c'est cette attaque le pion ces
trois cavaliers 2 on protège le pion ces
trois-là fait un coup de défense fossett
perde assez tranquille loin alors pas
mal parce que ce fou peuvent jouer
peut-être x 6 avec envisagé devenir l'
attaque du tout de ces 30 c'est pas
évident encore s'est pas fait mais enfin
j'ai cinq quand même empêche fous et ils
n'ont pas choisi ce petit rock directeur
sportif n'a pas peur pour une raison
très simple les blancs sont en retard il
a réussi à prendre l'initiative dans l'
attaque lui comme ça comme une course au
départ stéphane les blancs attaque
clairement à droite et les noirs gauche
c'est une course
il faut donc gagner la course est ici
par son service de qualité garry
kasparov a gagné cette course puisque
maintenant les blanches ou h 4000 sont
encore à deux coups de la première
menace la g5 un g6 rete gas va dire à
4-4 au refus il ya un coût de la
première menace car il prend un échec
gagnant verra s'il ya toujours six tours
contre pied ses pions c'est déjà presque
équilibré ça commence à ça commence à
faire cher niveau matériel dont il faut
se méfier
en plus il a toujours des cinq à sa
disposition gaskarov fou c'est un donc
la vie des sections prend sept royaumes
foulée de après juste montrer quelques
coups encore pour montrer les noirs qui
se déploie cavaliers aux 5 h 5
les blancs penser qu'ils sont sur le
point d'attaquer des 5 et l'art dit stop
on regarde le foot bessette qui devient
extrêmement fort le fou et 7 qui ressort
de sa boîte
le canadien 5 centraliser le
veut dire quatre qui peut prendre ces
trois quand il veut les noirs ont une
position d'attaqué superbe
vous pouvez regarder un peu cette
position en famille ou en compagnie d'un
partenaire échiquéen et vous verrez que
ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup d' attaque
donc ce sacrifice en c3 marche
effectivement il faut se donner les
moyens d'arriver à le faire donc pour ça
il faut revoir le développement de garry
kasparov
après fo ou trois bons joueurs aussi ce
f3 b5
donc en fait on peut tout de suite dire
que l'idée c'est de sortir de tourabi de
stefan wey si on veut trouver des moyens
de se rappeler de ce qu'est en train de
se passer puisque b5 l'idée
éventuellement trouver des 4 est vendu
probablement tout bessette et donc de
libérer la casse et vite pour la tour
d'amd 2 les blancs font leur truc que
les dix-sept là on peut le faire parce
qu'il ya page et 5,13 à présent se
rappeler qu'en cas de g5 en cas de g4
des blancs en 4g 4 il faut pouvoir
mettre le carrière si sur la classe 17
voilà donc si j'ai quatre
eh bien c'est ce qu'avait dit la qui va
passer d'abord grand roque fou bessette
g4 la la panacée g5 donc qu'elle ait des
six maintenant sa menace régulièrement
b4 à cause de ce coup qu'elle et ses 4
s'il est blanchi
cavignaux 2 donc on menace de enlever ce
cavalier c3 de le rapatrier en bien où
il est mal placé d'un f2 donc quasiment
obligatoire maintenant le quai c3 n'est
plus défendu mais il ya une menace
stéphane quel point 6 comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure que le 17 on part la
menace est ici si les blancs font la
force de jouer roi bien ce qu'elle fait
une obsession à la place de détroit eh
bien vous jouez tour s'est vite et le
sacrifice en c3 menaces et ne peut pas
être évité ouais mais difficile
puisqu'on a vu que sur qualifiés aux
deux et bien le coup des 5 ou le coup
qui a laissé 4 vous donner une très très
belle position
voilà donc là je pense qu'on a bien vu
une fois de plus toutes les manoeuvres
des noirs qui au fond ne change pas
beaucoup
quelles que soient les coudes et blanc
puisque les planches sont toujours les
mêmes qu'on les coudes attaques sont
thématiques
il ya pas moyen de les améliorer donc
les planches vont dans des ordres
différents les coûts à vous de voir les
bonnes subtilité dans deux coups mais le
plan des noirs restera toujours le même
nouvelle partie stephen la nouvelle
parking parti à vendre kasparov donc là
on va voir ce qui se passe quand les
blancs ne joue pas avec grand roque donc
position c'est celle-là faux droits nous
sommes dans une position b 5 g 4
maintenant qu'elle va dire f17 ouais
parce qu'il faut qu'on replace nos
cavaliers en b 6 et 17
et comme on l'a dit déjà plusieurs fois
c'est ce cavalier l'ad'abord sinon y'a
g5 qui pousse notre dame des deux qui
est des six il faut être précis
tentative d'aaland dans cette position
je joue à quatre alors la a4 le problème
c'est que ça affaiblit le grand coup
exactement c'est un problème totalement
philosophique on a joué g4 d'un côté on
joue à quatre de l'autre
où est ce qu'on va rauque et voilà ce
qu'il faut se demander bon alors
évidemment à nombre c'est pas le joueur
le plus faible de la planète
il y à penser et à penser qu est ce qui
s'est dit il s'est dit voilà les doit on
pas sorti deux pièces moi j'en ai sorti
4 donc je suis mieux il faut que j'ouvre
la position c'est maintenant que je vais
faire le petit rock mais je vais quand
même aller taquiner le pion à 6 donc ici
vous prenez en a quatre il faut
absolument pas laisser les blancs jouer
avec rock
donc si on joue b4 les plans vont se
replacer ils vont jouer qu'à l'idée
inquiète f2 et ensuite ils vont
peut-être joué les grog
c'est possible donc on ouvre les lignes
on prend quatre cavaliers prend cabanier
prend tout reprend et ne rend pas senti
aux sorties aucune pièce d'anton sortie
aucune pièce un élément sortis 4 mais il
n'y a pas de faiblesse par contre il ya
l'option ainsi move est un peu faible
pour l'instant très bien défendu et
loire au problème des blancs dans cette
position en fait c'est pas les noirs qui
qui ont fait quoi de ce code spécial
c'est blanc qui n'ont plus d'abri pour
leur voix très important donc on joue
face est donc maintenant il développe
tranquillement il dit simplement ben
vas-y cherchent un abri pour trois
exactement moi je sais où je vais mettre
le mien je vais jouer avec petit rock
avec mes pions 9 ans puisque tu as tour
en 4 peut pas vraiment m'attaquez in
situ faut de petit rock petit rock un
petit rock voilà mais avec le roi un peu
en l'air le roi un peu à l'air et
notamment garry kasparov donc
est très fort dans ce genre de position
ici il a tout de suite penser penser au
plan d' attaque dans cette position il
s'est dit je vais jouer avec elle cinq
et je vais lui casser toutes ces cases
blanches
donc il joue faux bessette tour f à un
cahier 17 eyeless leveleux fois le pian
la fille et la structure ainsi soit il
s'en [ __ ] du racisme garry kasparov
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que sur fou
prend 1,6 il ya toujours stéphane
cavaliers non il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
encore d'avis le 5
je sais qu'il a une bonne technique je
crois qu'on peut enfin de toute façon le
roi va se retrouver très faible le roi
va se retrouver très faibles donc vous
pouvez donner lecture à 6 dans cette
position je vois pas d'explication
rationnelle on va regarder on va essayer
de voir tout à fait me faut pour 1,6
tout simplement le cavalier ces scènes
où elle a gagné ses 5 et c'est
exactement ça voilà attaque la torah 4
et 6 passes ou faut prendre 17 il ya
tout reprend 1,4 exact mais là le
problème c'est plus fois ci s'est hâté
le foie si cette attaque et on va le
prendre près d'après donc il ya une
fourchette en fait non immédiate sur
fond pour 1,6 donc avant que le cahier
b3 plan logique pour jouer cavalier à 5
qui va attaquer le foot mais c'est vrai
mais c'est pas mal ça qu'elle soit on
fait tomber vite ou malin on va regarder
la suite fois cette tour ses mythes qui
avait dit à 5 fu habite une tonne le
pion à six mois mais mes gardes
il joue cavalier eux cinq ils donnent la
qualité non puisque le contrevenant à ce
qu'est pour f3 fourchette tension et sur
x 2 maintenant il joue f5 et là la
pression blanche s'écroule comme un
château de cartes
photo laurent blanc surtout le roi blanc
puisqu'on voit le cavalier à 5 hors jeu
le x 7 hors jeu les deux tours sur une
colonne on sait pas ce qu'elles font là
alors que toutes les pièces noires sont
prêtes à la tâte le kode5 2 x 8 et la
tour eiffe le foie ville qui est très
fort dans son coin là bas il comprend la
grande diagonale et et on voit en voit
très bien que les plans ne peuvent pas
tenir le centre là les menaces sont très
fortes
exactement exactement donc ici net
avantage pour les noirs donc vous voyez
quand les blancs ne joue pas et grand
roque
c'est ce qui a été choisie par un angle
dans cette position après que six fois
aux 3b 5 g 4 kelly a été cette dame des
deux qui est des 6 à 4 ils ne vont pas
jouer broc il faut absolument pas leur
en laisser l'opportunité donc comprendra
quatre très important on ouvre les
lignes complètement
c'est le grand que plus possible aux
grandes et plus possible et maintenant
c'est petit rock nous
une structure solide autour de nos 3 et
il va falloir attaquer laurent blanc
ensuite à droite de l'échiquier
une petite dernière juste pour avoir une
idée supplémentaire
non c'est pas celle là où est-elle la
voilà donc c'est encore un an
kasparov mais une autre version f 3 o6
toujours pareil faut trois des cinq les
années 2 de kébé 17 puisque j'ai cinq
est menacée g cap kébé 6 à 4
configuration légèrement différente
puisque ici kasparov a joué qui laissait
4-way donc un autre coup c'est un autre
coup c'est un autre un autre choix
c'est exactement la même position donc
effectivement cette partie ne présentent
pas l'intérêt que je pensais donc
simplement on va pas vous la montrer
puisque il faut se contenter de pions
prendra 4 qui est très bon dans cette
position donc stéphane pour résumer le
plan des noirs dans la vente principal
quand les blancs jouent avec grand roque
qui la plus dangereuse
c'est de jouer des 5 c'est de jouer des
simples coups libérateur de jouer tour
s'est vite éventuellement menacer tout
est à reconstruire et à la base au
départ qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut penser à les mettre sa tour en
sémites donc jouer le faux bessette est
également le remplacement de ceux des
autres cavaliers oui tout à fait
toujours cette manoeuvre cavaliers 617
et puis on a vu kasparov mettre son
cavalière à 4 pour attaquer les pions c3
tout à l'heure oui des fois ça va lancer
quatre aussi le deuxième cas bien que
ces cinq exactement donc voilà les plans
il faut très vite enlevé le cavalier
hayes 6 ne pas le laisser sur cette case
où ils risquent de donner des temps au
blanc pour attaquer supplémentaire donc
replacements des cavaliers le fond 17
l'atout ensuite pour menacer le
sacrifice en c3 tout ça vers l'idée
unique la libération des six des 5 cette
variante stéphane c'est bon tu va la
jouer puisqu'on sait que tu vas jouer
deux tournois cet été welch emploi de
paris et le championnat de france
aimerait donc ça y est la neige d'or
fait pas recette on aperçoit way
peut-être peut-être jeter tout et ça
c'est un salaire très intéressant à
jouer
on vous remercie d'avoir suivi cette
émission merci stéphane
d'abord nous avons assisté à de très
loin la prochaine fois à la prochaine
fois et donc évidemment la prochaine
fois ça sera encore la ccyn âge d'or
merci